if you've got a thousand dollars I would
like just keep investing yourself until
you got another thousand and then invest
in yourself you should start making
money faster you know there's things I
bought that I didn't get a return on
right away but I didn't quit investing
in a course or a workshop or training or
education because it didn't work I spent
17 years going to school none of it was
any good for me it did teach me how to
go to school how to study how to go
there how to complete a course like I
completed college you know I think you
just got to keep invested in you and
what we do is we start taking it off the
table I think people just need to get on
that cycle of like okay I'm going to
keep repeating this activity I'm going
to reinvest the money in myself go to
the workshop or whatever Monday I got to
be hustling again until okay now I got
four thousand dollars okay now I got
five thousand now the income's starting
to pick up income has to pick up until
one day you're like okay I have more
money here than I can actually invest in
myself I can't like there's nothing I
can go to to get rid of this money you
need to get rid of that money though
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your Circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Grant Cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two focus on making money I
did it all over again today I would the
first thing I would learn today
is the Money Gang
I believe this is the single most
important thing your staff can learn
your Executives can learn uh your your
financial person your CEO by the way the
person your CFO your your Chief
Financial Officer they don't even know
anything about finances what they
actually actually let me change that
it's not that they don't know anything
about finances what they know is
actually one of the people holding you
back
uh
[Music]
the kpi
the return the Met we're not getting a
Roi on this investment
the return on investment is terrible
this is not a good return
you know like like you got to understand
they're counting money
they're not creating it
right so our expenses are too high
we need to reduce our expenses and we
pay sales people too much money
in our in our company number one most
important protected group in the company
is the sales team
I think we gonna overpay anybody if we
overpay anybody it is the guy and the
gal that is going out bringing in the
kill
that's right
okay so the income line man this money
thing this money game this is this is
how a financial statement Works income
expenses
net
okay
I I screwed the whole deal up
I spent more time on this line than I
did on this line how many of you know
people do this reduce the expenses
reduce the expenses reduce the expenses
reduce the expenses how low can you go
to zero
how high can you fly
see I can take this number to Infinity
I can only take this number to zero
everybody agree
so I spend today 95 percent of my time
on income and less than five percent of
my time on expenses
so your your your financial officer is
spending all their time on what
uh this expense and that expensive where
this went where that went I saw Brandon
the other night we went to dinner with
Brandon and some of his clients
some of this very very special Elite
clients and
um we were having dinner and and Brandon
when the bill came and Brandon picked up
the bill and and and he took a picture
of it I said why are you taking a
picture of it well to send this to the
to whoever collects history because once
it's an expense is history
everybody agree
now have you ever gotten rich
and that's what accountants do they
record history something that was done
where's your where's your future going
to come from
income is the future right so I spend 95
of my time on two things marketing
and income
and if I spend too much big deal I'm
gonna go find this is the solution to
all my problems marketing and income
everybody agree
I'm gonna go expand Netflix Amazon Apple
Google dude they don't worry about their
expenses they're like how much can we
spend how many people can we hire how
big can we get how long can we bleed
and one day we'll own the world rule
number three get more productive a lot
of people don't get who I am because
you know because I'm Brash and I'm
Bodacious and I do and I probably just
say things wrong
and
I don't I don't really think through how
I'm gonna say something I just say it
and then let it the chips fall where
they fall but
I want the people around me doing well
like I don't wanna I'm not the guy I'm
here by myself today but most of the
time I'm rolling with a crew I want them
all doing well I want those guys making
money
I don't want people suffering around me
I want people
I know that when we go someplace they
want to pay the bill to
I mean the wine when the wine list comes
out I know the guys I work with are like
hey Grant whatever whatever you want bro
just get it on me
everybody wants to pay that big check
so
I think I I you know the weight of 10x
is to make sure you're doing well and 10
other people not other people are doing
well that's the big 10x
you know you fix your house and nine
other houses on the street or you don't
fix the houses you you get the
neighborhood in a condition where
everybody's fixing their own house and
the value of the neighborhood comes up
and then the schools and then you reach
out 10x further than that and the
schools are better and then the firemen
are getting taken care of the police or
maybe we don't even need a police
department anymore because everybody's
so freaking sane now people aren't
killing each other and not hating on
each other not beating the wives
the amount of dumb stuff we do and that
I've done
when I'm when I when I'm working when
I'm on course when I'm like when I'm you
know I'm not bothering other people
I think if everybody just got more
productive on
fulfilling their own potential nobody
would have time for Wars drugs you
wouldn't even have time to go find a
drug dealer you'd be like I'm sorry I'm
gonna oh yeah
you know I'll get it later but right now
I got this
if I can make it
I have not collaborated with other
people I didn't come for money I had no
connections
I have refused to like
not be myself and yet somehow I
made it
and so the one thing is like if you just
don't quit if you don't quit if you
refuse to quit you will not fail rule
number four follow your gut I disregard
my feelings like like my feelings you
know feelings are overrated in our
society like he
they're gonna mislead you they're not I
gotta follow my gut no no I don't even
know what you're talking about you most
people don't even know where their gut
is their gut your gut is a it's a
stomach it's called a stomach okay it's
not designed to lead you it's designed
to digest food so so I I don't I follow
the data right and and my emotions my
emotions fear would keep me from doing a
fears kept me from doing I should be I
should be a billionaire eight or nine
times right now what is it fear fear
kept me from doing these the deals I'm
doing today fear kept me from doing 20
years ago so what were you actually
afraid of I I was afraid I lacked
confidence in in the data I didn't I
didn't trust the data I knew I have
known for years this little space that
I'm in
um I mean in so many different places
but particularly in the real estate I've
known for years that there was going to
be a massive shift in America
particularly and maybe around the world
to where people will no longer buy homes
and they will live they will they will
lease where they live and they will move
around the country their Mobility would
become a big thing and I knew that I
knew that but I did I should have put
every penny I should have borrowed more
money I should I should own 40 000 units
down not uh seven thousand
so maybe maybe 70 I could be one of the
biggest landowners in America today had
I followed my in my my data my instincts
that was backed by data rather than my
feelings and listening to the numbnuts
around me that are like don't do it
don't take the risk you don't need to
you already have enough all you're going
to do is like all that input from other
people you know we I bought a I bought a
plane uh maybe three or four years ago
and I've taken a bunch of meat about the
plane because people are like oh he's
showing off his plan look if you had a
guy if you had a jet you would show it
off too and if you didn't show it to
people
uh shame on you like it's inspiration
for most people not envy for most people
they're like did that inspires me Mark
Wright was here yesterday
he was on you know Mark I've was sure he
was all depressed he was The Apprentice
from the Lord oh yes yes so he flew with
me from Cardiff to uh London last year I
put him on the plane he says Grant you
ruined my whole life put me on that
plane I can't think like every time I
get on a plane now I'm like oh my God I
need that flat private it it is a like
it is a Ruiner and this is what like if
I inspire people to think bigger that
that is one of my goals because that has
been the big ruin of my life that I
didn't think big enough the whole time
the big single biggest regret I have in
my life I played it small
for
at least 35 years
influenced by Society education friends
even friends with good intentions family
members that love me you know they're
the wrong people
to let the the you know the foul country
I did yesterday the the one of these
birds the Peregrine pair of Paris
something moves to 200 miles an hour
makes an aerial strike kills on contact
like it's like wow man it only had it
only it only does three things in his
life it either kills you gets killed by
you or has sex with you
simple what a life also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five learn the finance
game you guys have to learn this Finance
game it's a different game than your
moms and dad uncles and aunts and your
gramps played okay they were trying to
pay everything off they were trying to
earn money you really in in today's
society you don't really want to earn
money you have to do that in the
beginning but what you want to do is you
want to get money or equity you really
want money to become equity and you want
the equity to go up Elon Musk posted or
tweeted Sunday
he's like I know there's a lot of talk
about the capital gains tax
he said but you guys need to understand
and there's a lot of talk about
billionaires paying taxes he's like you
guys need to understand I don't earn
income
I can I only pay taxes when I sell
shares of my Tesla
and and and so like people need to
understand that's the game you know my
dad wanted to earn more money my dad
wanted to get into the middle class my
dad wanted a better job my dad wanted to
have more money so he could buy a house
so he could pay it off he could he could
buy life insurance for the family he
could pay that off he could uh have
money left over for a savings account or
a money market or you know
stuff right but but you see that's not
the game guys the game is to study the
top the top wealthiest people in the
world and what they're doing is they're
they're Jay-Z talks about Equity he's
like yeah you're going you're going for
the advance I'm going for the equity
you know and and when you're on the up
when you're trying to get up you're
trying to get that Advance you want the
bag so bad
that we never learn how to keep it and
then we never learn how to multiply it
rule number six get multiple sources of
income I'm out I have one income in the
beginning and and what do I need what do
I need in addition to one income I need
a second income that I ideally don't
have to work for okay I don't want the
second income to take attention from the
first income
this is where people make a big mistake
they go out and get one income they bust
in their ass to get one income and then
they go invest in a second thing start a
second company and the second company
makes the first income happy income
because they don't pay attention to it
anymore I wanted my first income to grow
my second income to take zero attention
from me so what I did was I took money
from the first threw it in real estate
like I'm showing you in the back here
that's playing on my TV right now this
is a deal we're doing right now put the
money in the real estate I don't lose my
money I know it's not going to go down
in value
it's supported by cash flow and three I
just wait for the growth of rent
so all we buy is and and this is why I
would say no to people on bitcoin right
now and ethereum any of the coins number
one you could lose your money
if if if you're just getting started you
don't lose money man number two you're
not getting income none of the coins pay
income crypto does not pay income and if
you're 25 35 years old you need income
not just a score
now all that being said
how does how does my real estate compare
to crypto or Amazon
well I can tell you that that piece of
real estate that I'm showing you right
there I'm gonna pay 230 million dollars
for that I'm gonna sell for a half a
billion dollars
and I'm gonna be paid to wait for a for
a hundred percent return on the total
price
but because it's the real estate
I only I don't pay the whole price I'll
pay you about 70 million for that
property
70 million will become
500 million
uh which is about a six x return with no
threat of loss
income while I wait and great tax
advantages rule number seven be honest
with yourself I always thought that I
could do something I I think everybody
thinks anything everyone does that yeah
I think everybody does I think every
person thinks that they're special
but do you think if they would if they
would be really honest and not not I
think that they have the thought and
then and then they're like I can't tell
anybody that because that white people
will judge them well they will judge
them they will judge them like your
parents will tell you you're special
until you start acting like you're
special and then they want to medicate
you so like oh you're so special you
know he's so special right and then and
then then special becomes a problem
somewhere between I don't know eight
years old and 15 special takes on a
different meaning than it than if you're
24 months old and then and it becomes a
problem for the adults right so I think
everyone is special I think if everybody
got really quiet
and anything you could say anything they
everybody would be like yeah dude I got
this special little thing I got this
superpower I got this you know this
thing and then what happens is it gets
squelched for me I squelched it so hard
I suppressed it and pushed it down so
hard because because I was told to like
it was not
the the
my surroundings did not like me
exhibiting
my my special right so so you know
because because I was awkward was
special like in the beginning you don't
know how to use it so for me I've always
been very uh rough uh I was in Dubai and
this lady says oh my God I loved meeting
this guy she was I saw her write an
article about me I love meeting this guy
he's a bit rough but but and I've always
been that I've always been a very kind
of the edges are Jagged do you know who
has a reason for that because I'm trying
to figure it out I'm trying to figure it
out it's and still be me without without
suppressing who I am right so I'm trying
to I'm I'm a bit I'm very playful uh I'm
immature
I I love pranks I like having fun more
than I like anything like I want to have
fun but I want the fun but but then I
then I've become very serious when it's
time to work so I go from this
very playful person to this extremely
intense
uh uh hard-working
it can happen in a
you know that we could be you know
screwing around doing something dumb to
okay now we're in a deal and the phone's
on and like I'm in the deal now do you
know that adaptability has helped you
get to what you are yeah I think it's
helped me and hurt me though because it
because it's very confusing for people
even people very close to me I get it
yeah so I could I remember it reminds me
of a time when Elena and I my wife
she went she bought something I forget
what it was I said how much was that and
she's like I don't know I said find out
how much it was you got to know what
things cost because that bothered me
like I don't know
and then she told me I'm like Helena
that was ridiculous we didn't need it
instead you know I could have got a
better deal blah blah blah it was no
money I don't know it was 500 bucks or
something
literally three minutes later I was
negotiating a deal and bought it for 62
million dollars or something so
ridiculous
so I went from being micromanaging
probably incorrectly over 500 bucks to
spend 60 60 million dollars and she and
she it was confusing for it's confusing
for the people around you
you know when you're making decisions
like on your whiteboard saying you know
what I'm going to throw away my main
business I'm gonna go away I'm gonna go
for this other business it it scares
people when you start changing rule
number eight never stop learning I
wasn't good at the construction work and
I wasn't good as a salesperson so I lost
six sales jobs I lost and it wasn't
until I made a commitment to say I'm
going to get great at this game which
means I need an education and I started
going out and read books and like you
guys have grabbing audio
uh I mean that was Zig it was who was
the first guy the first guy I ran into
was no it wasn't Jim it was no it wasn't
Brian no he's still alive no it wasn't
Napoleon Hill it was uh but but I've
read all that stuff I'll think of the
guy's name here did something stick out
for you though because I you know yeah
the audio cassettes in the book and you
stuck them in the car and you listen to
the stuff
I listened to it like I didn't listen to
all the guys I I what I would do is go
deep on one guy I would go so deep on
that one guy that I knew everything
every little thing like I didn't study
seven eight nine people I I
wish Jake is and I know who Roan is and
all that but there was a guy that was
doing some kind of training in the
industry I was in he had a program and
that's all I studied was that program I
listened that program five thousand
times I mean without exaggeration in the
morning at night in the morning at night
over and over I never got tired of it
I I got to where I was discovering
little nuances
and pauses
and and then I became a professional I
mean it was like and it was almost
instant
and it was and he was doing the car
industry before well I was in at that
time at 25 I was in the automobile
industry hated the industry hated the
business didn't really like selling cars
um
I was in the wrong vehicle I knew I was
frustrated because I knew I was in the
wrong I couldn't get rich there it was
impossible and
um so when I started my business at 30
and I said I'm going to go teach people
a different way to sell things because
one thing that happened and why listen
to the all these trainers was there was
a lot of trickery going on
yeah you know there was a lot of these
guys were just speakers they uh never
made it they really never made it sales
people they went from sales people to uh
sales presentations yeah and this was
once I started looking into the space a
lot of charlatans a lot of the earlier
people we talked about that never had
businesses they're like I created more
millionaires but you don't have a
million yeah
like where's your business that still
exists today your only business is you
you hop around the planet speaking like
I was in uh what where were we last year
uh London and the guy says you're you're
one of the top three speakers in the
world and the interesting thing is the
other two guys
or full-time speakers and you're not I'm
running 14 little companies you know on
the phones after this but we're doing
deals we're bouncing on a 200 million
dollar deal this morning and that's what
I'm doing every day now it just so
happens I I love people and I remember
that young 25 year old grant that wanted
some help and direction
and so Cardone University was for for a
way a way for us to put my material on
somebody's phone and be with little
Grant
before deal during a deal after the deal
like we literally have people taking
excuse me one second sir going out
grabbing a phone know where the material
is pop in what would Grant do right now
yeah and that that's the way that
program was created rule number nine do
not diversify people don't get wealthy
diversifying they don't accumulate
wealth they may preserve it by they
preserve it later later they might do it
uh by the way Warren Buffett would if
Warren Buffett could own all the
Coca-Cola or AIG which is what he
started with he would he can't
uh he he has of all his Investments four
of his Investments four represents 75
percent of his entire portfolio Mark
Cuban said that uh diversifications for
idiots uh Elon Musk has three
investments in his portfolio all of
which he wants Steve Jobs had two
Investments Pixar and apple it is not
true only the financial planner only the
financial planner who might not even be
a millionaire would suggest that you
diversify or or Wall Street or the banks
a banker will tell you to diversify but
there's no Bankers got four billion
dollars worth of assets
so I got four billion dollars worth of
this real estate right here
and and you know
I have two million dollars worth of uh
Bitcoin
so I only have the Bitcoin because
somebody gave it to me
that's a big gift Grand yeah yeah well
they yeah yeah so so I and I added a
little bit once I understood it but or
partially understood it but this stuff
right here look I know
I know that monk cash is garbage
Euros pounds
pesos whatever you want to call it
Spanish dollars it's all garbage it's
completely made up
um you know I I like the argument for
crypto I don't like the fact that when
you're on the come up and you're 35
years old what you need more than
anything is income
you need a flow of income that you can
depend on so that if you're not working
or can't work or something happens you
still have income to pay for your rent
or pay for your food because you still
got to eat and most people I haven't
seen anybody going to the food to the to
the store and trading their crypto for
some Whole Foods
you mean there's no yield in crypto
there's no useful exactly there's no
cash flow and now
if you're a gambler
dude and you want to put it all oh I
would never put it all in why wouldn't
you see this is the question I ask
people dude if you know for sure crypto
is a play if you know it's going to the
moon the Dogecoin if you know for sure
it's going to go to a hundred thousand
then put everything in it but see I'm
not that sure
so because I'm not that sure I can't
make that big bet
and the way to create real wealth is to
make massive bets if particularly
particularly with your story about hey I
don't want to wait till I'm 90 years old
and Warren by the way Warren started
when he was 50. he didn't make any real
money until he was 50 years old but I
would just tell people look if you want
to make massive money then you need to
put you need to go all in first on you
second on your business not on real
estate or crypto the best return in the
world is your business the best return
in the world is an idea I got an idea
I'm gonna write a book I go out and sell
a million copies of a book there's no
better return than that
because it came from nothing right it
came from the mud
um now once you got money coming in from
the book sales how do you protect the
money okay well you you go all in on one
stock uh you could go by Amazon today
for thirty thirty five hundred dollars
but I'll tell you this piece of real
estate right here will make more money
for me and my family than Amazon will
ever make
because what will happen with this real
estate that you can't do with Amazon and
you can't do with Bitcoin I'm going to
wait 10 years on this piece of Real
Estate
I'm going to take all my Capital out of
the deal
I'm going to refinance it still own the
asset and get my down payment back so
I'll get my 70 million dollars back or 7
million whatever the number is this is a
big big deal so it's 230 million dollars
I could take it down to 20 million or I
could take it down to two it's the same
math all the way across the board it's
just different zeros yeah
no but but this asset class this
particular asset class allows the
everyday person
to create wealth in a way that Wall
Street has been doing for years which is
uh buy an asset it goes up in value
because because the income goes up
without my effort
and then when it goes up in value I
refinance it grab my initial monies out
of it now I have that money back it's a
non-taxable event worldwide by the way
worldwide that becomes a non-taxable
event
I refinanced the property it continues
to cash flow and pay me money but I have
no money in it this is the true wealth
formula uh which where we're using
leverage against an increased assets
value going forward and Rule Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is help others I would pick
helping
over everything so so only because my
heart kind of pulls me to help people
because I wanted help when I was a kid
and
um I didn't have anybody to help me and
it was frustrating and I just I I have
this personal promise that I made years
ago that if I ever made it I would
um I would stay revealed and I would
help people I would show them what I'm
doing so
um
and that thing pulls at me it probably
cost me you know a lot of time and
energy because but but it pulls me it's
just it's kind of like a mission to
Steve Harvey told me once he's like you
know Steve Harvey he's got this
beautiful saying about he his career is
what pays his bills but his
mission is what pays his heart or
something like that he says it much
better than I do
spirituality is the number one most
important thing to me in my life like
before my wife and my kids is my
understanding of God yeah and and my
dreams come from that connection and
that understanding and my my dreams and
my goals are not really Financial it's
potential
so so so when I talk about
you know people ask me
the probably the most painful question I
get is when is enough enough
and I'm like man you guys are to check
in with God on that
yeah right because because my my
potential
is what I'm going after it's not it's
not some number I got a guy asking me
about my net worth I'm like dude what
it's a stupid question
it's the ego it's an ego it's an ego
thing right what I'm interested in is my
potential possibility discovery
and and and for me that potential is the
thing that strings me and God
and that potential is my dreams it's
like what what could I do what's
possible
and the the other thing is about the
blessing you know you hear people I was
in Atlanta I'm like man I'm blessed and
everybody's like oh yeah praise the Lord
I'm like yeah everybody's blessed
everybody's blessed I've never met
somebody that's not blessed
most people are not proving it though
they're blessed and not validating God
every day wow so uh I have a very very
powerful very strong and very clear
understanding of my relationship with
God and it is first and foremost with me
other people won't understand it right
but but but I every every day every day
every deal undoing a deal
like I've undone deals hey guys this
deal is no longer good for me
and that was me at my my highest ethical
what do you mean you got a deal we got a
deal you signed a contract that's right
and now we're going to undo this deal
and I'm gonna undo it we're going to
talk about it we're going to figure it
out
hey hey this deal is not good for me and
if it's not good for me it's not good
for my family it's not good for my
future it's not good for my my ability
to give to Charities it's not good for
you either
so rather than me just walking away why
don't we just rework the deal so that
we're both happy and everybody went very
difficult thing to do
yeah because another person driver
because another person might be bound by
that agreement they're like no no we
have a deal I have to do what I said I'm
going to do because they're Bound by
some rule that they made some agreement
hey if that agreement's no longer good
for you no God would want you to
continue what you'd want to do is
communicate which is harder to do yeah
you know so so
the ability for my wife and I to
communicate about anything even if it's
tough and it's you know it's
you know how have it believing in God is
more than just believing in God it takes
courage
to to go out every day and validate it
because if you actually believe you have
to deal and you ought to do well too and
if you have a you know to me in my mind
like
you know if I have if I have a good
really strong good working relationship
with God I would be successful at
everything
physically in my marriage in business
with my customers online
I would have good reviews not bad
reviews yeah like you already have the
whole package I don't think
I know I don't think God had a partial
package I think it was probably the
whole deal
and the other thing is the work thing
you know like
I see a lot of people that believe in
God that don't work
you know they're like oh yeah but you
know
they're taking two and three days off
God don't even take that much time off
he takes one day off yeah look what he
did before he took the day off what you
become is what you will be
most people are sitting in the student
chair too long you're learning you like
learning studying reading you know
trying to get information dude the way
to the way to trick the system is to
become something as fast as possible
don't keep learning buy something this
is the easiest simplest way for somebody
to become an investor I did the deal I
bought the deal with my money did the
research with my money my time my energy
my 30 years I use my cred with the banks
and the real estate Community to get the
deal that deals 260 million dollars
your entire audience could not buy that
deal by itself even if it had the money
because it doesn't have the connection
yep so I'm paying I'm buying the deal
with my money and my bank of my my debt
then once I buy it and closed it I've
taken all this risk out
because once I buy it and close it then
I offered up to my audience and say same
price that I paid you can get in at one
thousand dollars five thousand ten
thousand whatever number you're
comfortable with so what happens is one
your money's protected against inflation
and deflation okay against the
disruption and destruction of the dollar
which is what what's happening right now
is they are purposely destroying the
dollar the very thing they told you for
the last 30 years you should save and
you should you should you know trade
your most valuable asset for they are
now destroying the very thing that
you've been saving
and they're penalizing you for having it
because they pay you nothing to keep it
understand that that a thousand and I'm
gonna answer your whole question here
understand that a thousand dollars today
at Bank of America or Wells Fargo
let me see a thousand dollars today
times pays one dollar and twenty cents
suppose
let me see yeah that's one dollar and
twenty cents anyway to do it crazy okay
now that's before you bought your checks
that's before you started the the
checking account that's before you use
the ATM by the time the end of the year
is your thousand dollars probably more
like 920 bucks probably cost you 80
bucks just to have a checking account
so number one you become an investor
number two you get cash flow every
quarter number three I expect that
building to be a double or a triple so
I'm paying 260 for the building if I
stole it for 340 we make a double I
think the building is going to sell for
500 million when I sell it
the location is ridiculous can't replace
it it's 99 occupied right now it's a
trophy quality asset it's in Fort
Lauderdale Florida one of the hottest
markets in the country and when I sell
this I will be selling it to an
institution and the reason that's
important is because most of us that are
earning 50 bucks a night
you have to buy The Leftovers man you
know the the we're buying leftovers
we're buying we're buying the garbage in
the community the duplex the single
family home these are the same homes
that went back to the banks in 2010 and
you don't want to be in that stuff what
you want to be is the trophy stuff that
somebody always finds value in yeah so I
think the return is uh five to six
percent in the first year paid out
quarterly
uh we passed through the depreciation to
you so you won't be paying taxes for the
first couple of years on your income
um and I think you get a double or
triple uh off your money so if you put
in 10 grand I think you're looking at
your money being 20 or 30 000 over the
next uh five six seven years the third
thing the super successful do is they
Master income creation I was asked this
morning I left my home at four o'clock
in the morning I was on a plane at five
okay and a guy asked me he's like dude
why you still cranking so hard
foreign
because I don't have any money I'm
always broke I reinvest all the money
every time I get any money sitting in
accounts I take it and invest it in hard
assets
illiquid assets
illiquids so that I cannot get that
money that's what keeps me motivated
folks
I get money liquid money
if it's not use what
it's useless take it and I buy a hard
asset
that produces income
I'm broke I gotta go hustle again the
thing is not to just be positive not
even to offer this no negativity policy
that I talk about the way to avoid uh
negative and distracting people man is
to vibrate at a rate so fast okay that
you're out in front of them once I got a
speeding ticket actually here in Miami
and the and the police officer says why
are you speeding why are you in such a
hurry I'm like dude I'm trying to stay
away from The Crazies
okay if I can just get ahead of
everybody else I'm not distracted by
anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so I got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what I'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people you need to take responsibility
that you're slowing down enough to get
caught up by this magnetic charge of
distractive and negative people dude you
need to vibrate so fast that these
people are distracting other people not
you get way ahead of the crowd get so
busy that nobody's gonna jack with you
man because you're filling up your
pipeline you're full you're busy and you
don't have this stuff sticking to you
look if you got negative people around
you if you got distracted people and we
all do but if it's causing you to be
distracted and negative dude you need to
vibrate you need to fill up your
pipeline you need to explode blow up get
busy so this isn't happening to you
because you're partly responsible Plano
to have life balance you got to have
money like yeah this is the taboo thing
to say it's never going to be on tv
nobody likes you got to have money
nobody's nobody ever says this yeah oh
yeah I do this I do that I have that
dude you gotta have money you can't you
can't
you know what do I mean by that like
okay well like create the life you want
yeah quit saving money
you know quit buying watches and H belts
like I don't have an Hermes built like I
didn't know how to pronounce Hermes I'm
like well who would spend seven 800
bucks on a belt like like I could buy
three thousand dollars but the real
estate with a seven hundred dollar bill
right and who am I trying to impress
anyway what I need is I need a trainer
to come to me so you buy your Army's
belt I'm gonna buy a trainer to come to
me I don't want to go to him
okay I know time is money
it's not money a sign it's time is money
so why am I going to get a car and drive
to to to to the trainer
here I'll give you another 200 bucks you
come to me
okay you come to me I walk down there I
do my workout boom I'm done well he's
he's still driving 40 minutes
and I'm already taking a shower and
doing a business deal
so you got to figure out the things in
your life
you know we're not when I when I went
from okay I'm never gonna do I'm never
going to work for below my pay grade
anymore
like this was a big shift for me
like I like gardening I like landscape
stuff right when I got rid of a yard I
was like that was that that probably
made me 10 million bucks
I loved it I spent too much time doing
it it was costing me money it was below
my pay grade
you know you see what I'm saying like
what am I doing what am I doing like oh
because it's therapeutic well good man
like like not two hours of it it's
Therapeutics cost you millions of
dollars because you're out there playing
with stuff that made me feel good and
everything but there's got to be a
faster better way to do that to get that
sensation 12 years ago we had done maybe
I don't know 20 million dollars over the
internet
we'd run over a billion dollars in sales
over the internet in the last 12 years
okay
thank you
[Music]
like you guys got to learn how to use
enthusiasm like when you use it use it
like the more you use the more you get
you like on the save my energy now and I
want to give them too big a hand too
early it's really early today come on
look man with somebody successful you
ought to throw down that's what I'm
talking about
thank you
see you guys you guys got it y'all got
y'all gotta quit trying little tricks
and gimmicks like if you gotta walk on
fire to get excited you are ramped up
like like if you can't at will whenever
you want to for any reason just get
excited
then you got a problem okay because in
real in the real world you can't you
can't be in the middle of a meeting and
I'm trying to get her to give me like a
hundred million dollars and I'm not I'm
feeling a little depressed or bad right
now or I got my attention on my kids and
and I'm like okay
[Music]
everybody's gonna be like nah we were
gonna give you 100 until you started
pumping your chest
right you can't say hang on a second man
I got to go into a state change
like that's not real you guys understand
you have to be able to that's a gimmick
and gimmicks take time okay and gimmicks
cannot be duplicated what can be
duplicated or disciplines
and that's what you're gonna be we're
going to be sharing with you over the
next three days disciplines can be
duplicated if you've seen my children
okay if you bet how many of you've seen
Sabrina and Scarlett those are
disciplines
okay if they were in here right now they
could get on that stage and talk to you
they know how to look you in the eyes
they know how to shake your hand because
they have been taught how to communicate
we spend less time on teaching them how
to count than we do communicate
connect with people okay we have them
homeschooled The Homeschool teacher what
do you want to learn you just keep
teaching them what I'm teaching them you
teach them confidence you teach them
Poise you teach them the ability to
communicate be dangerous not careful
okay we teach our kids how to be
dangerous I teach my kids how to meet
strangers and greet strangers we teach
our kids that strangers have everything
they want and strangers are not
dangerous
okay is there danger in the society yeah
that's what those guys are for over
there
so I'm gonna put my kids in an
environment where they can meet 99 of
the people and feel safe to meet them
talk to them communicate with them so I
want to make sure that my kids can walk
into an environment and have zero
concern about him her or him
and they can walk out and say Hey I want
to meet you because strangers have
everything that you want
the people you don't know and haven't
met These Guys these guys dressed in
their robes what do you call the robes
the Condor okay I have one in my closet
by the way I love the Condor I put the
Condor on one time and I was like I'm a
bad bad man
dude I felt so freaking powerful it was
amazing okay I grew a beard I'm like now
I'm a man
okay give me a camel
okay it was like it was like phenomenal
right like but but you you guys need to
have that kind of Swag everywhere in
life and regardless of how old you are
25 and you're like I'm too young to have
swag or 55 and now you're too old it's
not true you just need to get the
confidence the bravado not fake it you
don't need to fake it you need to you
need to get you need to get confidence
if I could get rid of this right here in
life if I could get rid of these Downs
man how confident would I be
I mean like I'm going into every deal
I'm gonna win
and that is possible folks okay but it
starts with who knows me
because if I'm walking around this
planet and nobody knows me I'm going to
be terrified you better get excited now
because if you're not going to get
excited now nobody will give you this
money
nobody will give you this money Money
Follows attention how much attention can
I get in the marketplace is where money
goes money does not go to the best
product ever money does not go to the
best product money does not go to the
happiest place either money goes to
where attention goes whoever gets the
most attention gets the most money
action Massive Action has always worked
it's proven itself for thousands of
years this is not a New Concept
you show me somebody and we know their
name anybody anybody in the in the in
the room any famous person
that you can think of
anybody that we would both know you say
I'm going to mention their name and
Grant will know who that is give me a
name of one person
Massive Action
persistent Massive Action okay
okay how many people were watching the
open yesterday
yeah exactly why
because tiger was in it attention Money
Follows attention
Money Follows attention how much
attention can you even bad attention
okay I'm gonna tell you something
what tiger went through in the last
decade helped him
you got more white people pulling for
Tiger Woods
right they're like tiger grown white and
tiger and we say there's division in
this country tiger I love tiger right
why because they love a comeback man the
guy got a lot of attention Okay who else
give me another name
oh my God I didn't I didn't know it was
going to be this kind of meeting
if I'd have known it was gonna be this
kind of me I'd charge a double
Donald Trump everybody knows it okay
Money Follows attention success and
power follow attention Okay you cannot
like the guy but could you handle
that much heat
every day
could you handle that many people not
liking you every day
because if you're going to be a leader
if you're going to be a real leader okay
if you're going to be at the top of the
food chain kind of leader people aren't
going to like you it's the question
everybody asks how do you do it all day
like like what you do if you want to get
it if you want to do it I'll quit
quit uh compromising on what it takes to
do it all and you know the the thing
that we confront at my house is money
and this is the thing that most people
are not confronting they're not
confronting
money what they're doing is they do
budgets
we have enough money to do this
I don't do a budget what I do is what do
I want
how much money does it take and then I
go create the money yeah you know this
is what we did thousands of years ago
when you hunted if you were hungry
you're like I'm hungry what do you want
to eat whatever you
what can we eat what can we kill what
can we get in my job my job back then
was to go out and and not not come home
dude until like I didn't have anybody to
blame you could blame brexit you can
blame you can blame everybody you want
to blame but but if your kids need to
eat yeah right so back then it was like
get food now it's like people are like
I'm just gonna take whatever they give
me and I'm gonna be I'm gonna I'm gonna
make sense of it as opposed to like what
life do I want I need a nanny okay I
don't want my kids to go to school I
went to school I went there I sat with
the other little uh numbnut uh loser
kids that I was
I was there to distract every child in
the room okay I had no interest in the
class
my job was to make sure he didn't learn
anything and that you and I had fun and
that the teacher went home
um and had the worst to ever life I
hated school so
um
I hated every second of it I don't want
to do that to my kids so what do I need
I need a nanny what's a nanny cost 80
grand a year oh then I got to bring her
around with me and feed her and then I
got to put her in a hotel room so I
needed another room so you guys started
doing the math and all this okay I don't
wanna I got my nanny I got two kids two
kids with us uh I got oh we want to
travel around the world what's that
going to cost what's it cost to be going
30 days and be in nice places that are
secure service a chef like no not none
of our parents got us ready for that
kind of budget yeah so it's great they
what they said was get a good job
your that job will pay 85 000 pounds and
make do with the 85 that is the wrong
way to do the math dude what kind of
Life do you want not not what can you
make sense of what kind of life
would allow you to have to be able to do
work
and life yeah uh oh wow man you know
what if I'm gonna if I'm gonna you know
travel I need a plane dude then you got
a new calculation to do then I need
Pilots then I need a place to keep the
plane then I need insurance and all of a
sudden the whole thing gets really
complicated and you're like damn I need
some money
but now now you start me you start
picking what what would produce enough
money
you start thinking creatively once you
commit you start thinking greatly again
look I started with nothing for me to be
doing what I'm doing today is because
I'm committed to figuring out I am as
committed to this
as the drug addict is committed to to
the heroin and he has no money whether
he has no money he his reputation sucks
he never he owes every drug dealer in
town and he'll still get his fixed he'll
still figure out how to get his deal
money's garbage
it's garbage it's not it's not really
what you want because it gets taxed
heavily
so and this is another thing the ball
players don't understand this most the
middle class doesn't understand it the
guy making 50 racks a year done the guy
making 500 racks a year doesn't
understand it guy working at Facebook
doesn't understand he knows how to code
he don't know how to beat the tax man
and the way to beat the tax man is with
real estate it is the last venue where
and I'm not talking about a house
I'm talking about buying like this piece
of real estate right behind me right
guys that piece of real estate is 260
million dollars
now I didn't start with that my first
deal was my first deal was a three
million dollar deal I made 5 million on
it one deal
and paid no taxes and when I did that
first deal man I did I put 350 Grand
down I borrowed it from my mom and a
brother
uh and made five I turned 350 Grand into
five million dollars and didn't have to
go through the [ __ ] that I was going
through every single day
and I'm like oh my God this is a game
man when I went to file my taxes the guy
showed me how not to pay taxes on it I'm
like okay I'm good
and I've been doing that I now have four
billion dollars worth of real estate I
started with 300 Grand borrowed money I
got four billion dollars this deal right
here is a quarter of a billion
and what I've learned over the last 25
years is this game is on it's on it's a
rigged game and it's on stack
it's all it's all stacked against the
little guy in the middle guy
and so what I decided to do was was I
promised my mom when I was 15 years old
Dorian I said if I ever make it I'm
gonna help the little guy out
because I grew up with a single mother
five kids she was freaking frightened
all that she never got a shot at that
stuff
you know if my family got to buy a house
that they had we had you got to pay for
if we could buy a house and pay it off
that was freaking like that was the
American dream
that ain't a dream bro that's prison
that right there behind me cash flow day
one
trophy asset
appreciation two and three and four
times most of this real estate's been
doubling every every decade
uh trophy institutional quality great
write-offs everything the wealthy look
for in an investment so I'm buying this
deal and then I open it up to my friends
and followers on Facebook Instagram Tick
Tock thousand dollars
with a thousand dollars you can partner
with me in that deal
and it's important for everybody to know
like oh my God this guy's gonna raise
money from everybody I could have gotten
one company One bank would have given me
the entire
amount of money that I'm raising for my
friends
One One bank said hey I'll give you the
whole two I'll give you all the money
for the deal and you you'd be the
partner in the deal Grant you run the
deal will be the money and I didn't take
the money because I want my friends my
followers the people on this I want to
give people a shot
so uh because you're you're easier to
deal with Dorian I'd rather you be my
partner in the deal than Bank of America
how did you get started like what was
your first company what did it look like
how did all that happen my first company
was working for somebody else you know
like until it wasn't until I figured out
how to make somebody else Rich that I
could be rich like I hear a lot of guys
saying I don't want to work for somebody
else I don't want to keep making other
people when I became successful in
another company
and then left that company and went and
worked for another company and made them
super successful to the point to where
these companies were literally dependent
upon me
like that that that's the thing that's
the muscle and the grit the the uh
persistence and fortitude of like you
know what I don't my ego wasn't like I
need my name on it but my ego was strong
enough to say I want to be the best
in the company like I want to make this
company dependent upon me the first
company the first real job I had was my
sixth job
I was fired from my first five fired
from my sixth job six times but wouldn't
leave the last one I just would not
leave so literally like I'd wrecked
stuff I I have a terrible driving record
and I was in the car business
and I'd wreck their cars and they'd fire
me and I say okay okay okay and I had a
bunch of other problems as well but
and then before I would leave I would go
sell something and then they would keep
me on if selling something was always
forgiveness
so um
when I finally left that company they
went under like they could my production
was so high that one person leaving the
entire company failed
went to my next job which was speaking
Consulting using my sales uh
philosophies
and gifts if you will uh and we would go
around companies and teach them
and
I worked for him for 20 months I was
like the top guy in this company now the
reason I'm saying that is that was a job
for me and that was a business I treated
that little my little Department like
this is my company within a company and
and I wanted to make that company as
strong as possible so that when I made
when I finally went out on my own which
I was forced to go out on my own I
didn't want to go out of my own I went
out on my own just because there was
just no opportunity left
and there was no way for me to score
where I was
which I I still remember today it's
important to get good people to keep
them that like you got to give them some
other
Pond to swim in
and so when I started my first company
uh I guess I was 29 that was a company
where I was cold calling on businesses
around the US and Canada what are you
willing to give up you guys got to keep
assessing the situation and not be not
be broad stroke about it and say I'm not
going to be a dilettante or I'm going to
be a professional I'm going to I'm not
gonna no no but what are you gonna give
up there are times though again when I
will give up
that agreement
see like one of the things I have on
here being right you have to give up
being right
you know you can't can't want to be be
right and be successful they don't even
go together
it's impossible so again I'm willing to
give up being right I just gotta don't
quit man if you don't quit if you don't
quit you can't fail
it's impossible failure becomes
impossible for those that don't quit
it's impossible just think about it if I
keep moving towards the destination if I
if I'm if I'm going through the alphabet
A B C D E dude if you just keep going
all the way to see you finish the
alphabet
break your leg along the way somebody
cut your tongue out you get waterboarded
you get a divorce you lose your dad you
lose a puppy
if you get to see you finish the
alphabet
period and boy when I heard that I'm
like God damn what was I thinking I was
thinking I could fail I can't fail if I
don't quit
so so that means I got to get rid I got
to dump people out of the car though
along the way right but we had to get
rid of a whole bunch of people
I I have to get rid of people how many
people have gone Johnny
huh I mean guys like if you saw the
wreckage
like so you don't see it you know oh I'm
not saying get rid of people I'm just
saying like like like what are you
willing to give up okay on my list I've
given up a house I've given up money I
gave up my retirement accounts I had
millions of dollars sitting in
retirement accounts I paid the penalty
to get the money
because it was a mistake years ago I got
convinced by the Banks to build an IRA
or 401K because I was trying to figure
out how to exit actually the people that
were giving me the advice were telling
me to figure out how to exit
you're planning an exit when you're 30
and it's stupid
think about what you're doing you're not
going to retire until you're 70. and the
rich people never worry about their
retirement accounts Warren Buffett has
not got a 401k he's got Coca-Cola
see the difference
see the difference in the think
okay so so like like you you guys have
to take a look at what you know that is
now a liability
what you know to be true that has become
a liability for you
and if you just study the middle class
of America study the entire structure of
the American economy you will see
you will see where a lot of these
liabilities exist that that are are
core values that you have not just for
you but for the entire population of
people
and and like if you just look at the
structure of America 311 million people
most of them are not doing well
you hear about it every day so the
solution is let's give everybody College
you know
let's give everybody coffee well College
could be one of the problems
look you know let's make sure everybody
gets through high school okay could be
one of the problems actually that it
takes 12 years to learn how to count
[Music]
and still no product
really
so anyway I'm not saying I'm not worried
about trying to change all that I'm just
saying you might want to look at how
some of that has influenced you
you know the retirement accounts the
life insurance how many of you got life
insurance
how many of you got some cash value
sitting there some hope
dude get the money don't wait till you
die I want to share with you the uh not
so secret way that thousands tens of
thousands actually millions of people
are becoming millionaires in America
today they invest in assets that
appreciate over time
yeah invest in assets
and IPS that they control
royalties they control things that they
know over time will increase in value
that there's a 99
99.9 chance that they're going to
increase in value and that's what they
invest in
they don't make little bets they make
big bets and they invest in things that
they know will go up in value over time
that could be a sports team
uh chances you buying a sports team are
next to none same for me
so you got to start thinking about okay
what assets can I do that with okay oh
wow I'm gonna go create I'm gonna go
create the next big thing
I'm going to create an app and
hundreds of millions of people are going
to download my app okay chance of you
doing that
uh your chances are bigger than mine
because I'm not even trying
there are assets out there today that
are in your backyard they're in your
neighborhood you don't have to buy a
sports team you don't need to be
connected you don't have to have a you
don't have to know how to write code or
do Tech it's sitting there waiting for
you right now
and it's one of the ways that I created
the wealth that I have in my life I have
we have 11 businesses today uh and and
then we have a real estate portfolio of
12 000 units going to forty thousand
units
and uh about four billion dollars worth
of real estate now the first 11
businesses that I own man they were so
hard
to create them start them manage them
guide them hire people for them
advertise Market get them known
like to organize it we have hundreds and
hundreds of employees in these companies
so about 700 employees across these
companies most of which are startups
they're brand new they don't have a lot
of employees a lot of risk a lot of
downside a lot of problems a lot of
headaches a lot of people the real
estate almost no headaches
compared to the value of the portfolio
very few people work at it it
appreciates the value over long periods
of time and that's what wealthy people
do they invest in assets real estate is
one of the things they love be a better
guy man I mean you know just be a good
guy and be be
you know the thing I'm proud of is I get
to be Grant all the time you know I'm
actually getting to the point where I'm
like hey man I finally got to be what I
I finally became what I wanted to be
what was that me yeah
you know that I don't have to apologize
anymore and then I quit screwing up and
I quit having to call people and say hey
man I I said I went too far you know if
I could just pull some of that back
without that drug that that psychiatrist
was trying to use right you know that if
I'm less dependent upon
aggression you know and I could I could
kind of manifest more you know like you
you talk about let it let it flow more
Let it Flow dude let it flow you know
but
but if I could get that perfect balance
of aggression and flow that's a sweet
spot yeah it's sweet dude it's hard to
find that thing same spot you know to be
that
I don't want to be I want I don't want
to be the little stream that drips you
know I want to be like but I don't want
to damage anybody right I don't want to
hurt anybody you know I don't want to I
don't want to be in competition anymore
but I also don't want to lose the edge
right you know it's a dance dude it's a
dance dance you know like like your girl
said to me the other night she's like
she said something before she left she's
like I really get who you are you know
that and that hits me when people say
that to me most people don't get who I
am that's beautiful you know and and she
said I really get who you are yeah and
and a lot of people don't yeah and it
sometimes it hurts right because I know
who I really am yeah and but I also know
the things I'm trying to accomplish for
me you know like Ryan Ryan gets who I am
you know Ryan Ryan never takes me on man
you're you're the best Queen you're the
best he just he Strokes me right right
yeah and and and you know my wife I can
see my wife she gets she gets tired of
the the pounding you know but hey man I
just you know I'm a right-handed hitter
you know or I got I got a certain ball
that I throw a certain shot I make and
yeah it's my go-to you know and when
when I get threatened I'm gonna go to
that
and if I could develop some other set of
skills you know that would be that would
be a cool thing this is insanity that
that you're being told don't monetize
your your business if you have a good
business have a good service have a good
product sell it
you know but so many guys are they're
trying these little kid kid gimmicks
you know it's fine if my kids flip shoes
on on on eBay
if you're an adult man you got to get
Beyond flipping
sneakers on ebay
you need to build a business
otherwise don't call yourself an
entrepreneur because that's not what an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is not
flipping on eBay
that's not a business that's you trying
to make two dollars
on a toy that you bought at a garage
sale it's a different gig now if you can
figure out how to scale that
but it sounds to me like you're you're
benefiting eBay more than you're
benefiting yourself
eBay eBay is the pimp and you're
basically the prostitute in that
Machinery which is no problem with that
right but you're servicing the machine
rather than building your own machine
I want to build a machine
I want to build a machine that lives
longer than I do so that if I get a good
partnership with somebody and we cut a
deal and they're 90 of the profits and
future and I'm 10 and my kids or my
charity get to keep that 10 after I'm
dead man I'm good to go
so what's next like go the jet like what
what's next man
man I don't know what's 10x for you now
10 X's you know how do I do a billion
dollars a year in in income
and then how do I do 10 billion in real
estate how do I have a 10 billion real
estate portfolio we paid last month we
paid
uh 1.4 million dollars out in
distribution I'm sorry last month we
paid 1.4 million in US dollars out to
our term investors in the real estate
how do I start compete with these Banks
so they're like you know what we really
don't like all this noise you're making
you're a noise if you've got and we're
kind of talk getting tired of it now
when you get noisy enough they either
buy you
and suppress you
you know that's what Bill Gates would do
with with apple years ago the tablet the
original iPhone was a little uh called
uh
what was the name of that little beast
um
anyway it had a little pin you wrote on
it they buried that project for years
um I'll think of it in a second I think
of it when the interview is over maybe
you guys know what it is okay anyways
probably 20 years ago I actually had a
company built around this thing and Bill
Gates came in Gabe Apple Steve Jobs
alone and said look I'll lend you this
money
you got to bury that product and they
did
so that's what you can do or they
consume you they buy you and say hey we
want you to be part of our
so maybe maybe that's what happens
Nathan I don't know
I don't know get to get the audio guy
the audio guy to get a good sticker for
the mic three things you got to know
about money
and the same three rules hold true for
attention number one you got to get it
you don't need to make it
it's already been made there's trillions
and trillions of dollars
there's more money on this planet than
there are iPhones okay endless supply
okay it's like it's garbage by the way
you need to understand it's garbage
once I get it the thing to do is once I
get it now I don't want to lose it how
do I not lose it I take it and I convert
it to something more valuable than money
so as fast as I can I'm gonna take this
cash that I earned I don't spend it ever
never spend this money no matter how big
the bag is I take the entire earned bag
and I dump it into something that
becomes that will produce passive income
for me the only thing I ever spend is
the hundred dollars that comes out of
the building not the bag that I earned
because of my talent
I take my talents I get paid for them I
shift it into the building the money
goes away
money can't be lost now it's been
converted to concrete glass steel
tenants leases
a real property okay it goes up in value
over time this gets destroyed over time
it can then get burnt it can get torn it
can get lost it can get uh stolen so I
want to get rid of this illiquid I want
to get illiquid in the building convert
it to something real and then I want to
wait when I get paid passive income this
passive income is not taxed it's only
taxed it's taxed up a small tiny
percentage of what earned income is so I
keep most of it and this is how I live I
live off of this money
and and I could spend all of this
or I could take this and start investing
in more buildings
the way you talk to me get it get it
keep it number two you got to keep it
how do I keep it I don't save it at the
bank
when you put at the bank the bank is
going to tax it
cash is taxed all cash is taxed okay
cash is not King cash flow is king So
what you want is you want this you want
passive income and the third thing you
want to do is you want to figure out how
they can multiply that building will
multiply over time there's nobody is
going to tell me that building will not
be more money right location
like like the cities we're buying in
Austin Houston Dallas Orlando Tampa uh
the Carolinas Nashville Tennessee
Atlanta Georgia if you're going to on
fire Savannah Georgia anything in the in
the smiley part of the United States
where New York when the vaccine when
they came out last night and said hey
we're mandating I got calls from three
buddies I'm done with New York
I thought they were going to change
they're not New York is going to feed
that building 20 of our tenants right
now are from New York City
10 percent are from California moving
from La all the way over to Miami
so people are tired of the [ __ ] man
and and and and when they're tired of
that what they do is they move and when
they move they rent first they don't buy
first
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one I did
recently with Grant check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created in best
Elon Musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses